[Musique]
un corps a été repêché ce mardi matin au
lac des Bretonnières de jouer les tours
celui d'une femme de 78 ans originaire
de balanmiré quatre plongeurs du service
départemental d'incendie et de secours
d'indrloire étaient intervenus peu avant
8h sur demande de la police nationale
qui avait repéré les affaires sur
lesberges ainsi que le corps il
s'agirait d'un
suicide un accident mortel s'est produit
ce mardi matin sur la commune de chisset
en Touren dans le loirécher une voiture
et une moto se sont violemment percuté
sur la route de Montrichard à Amboise le
motard s'est retrouvé coincé sous la
voiture l'homme âgé de 36 ans a succombé
aux suitees de ses blessures les quatre
occupants de la voiture en état de choc
ont pour leur part été transportés à
l'hôpital d'Amboise